[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn ich dich bitten würde mir eine
saubere energiequelle zu nennen welche
in der lage ist die zukunft zu gestalten
was ist das erste das tier dabei in den
sinn kommt nur je nachdem wie aufmerksam
er den titel dieses videos gelesen habt
könnten die meisten vielleicht auf
windmühlen oder solarzellen kommen doch
dieses mal werden wir hier auch visuell
politik über etwas ganz ganz anderes
sprechen von einem energieträger der
bisher kaum in unser leben getreten ist
aber von denen viele analysten glauben
dass er eine ganz neue revolution
auslösen könnte
[Musik]
die sprecher von wasserstoff und ja ich
weiß ist wasserstoff nicht das am
häufigsten vorkommende element im
universum
aber die sache ist die dass es auf der
erde nicht so reichlich vorhanden ist
[Musik]
100.000 55 prozent der atmosphäre
bestehen aus wasserstoff und der größte
teil des wasserstoffs auf unserem
planeten ist in wasser und
kohlenwasserstoffen enthalten also mit
anderen atomen verbunden zum beispiel
der alle wissen besteht ein
wassermolekül h2o aus zwei
wasserstoffatomen und einem
sauerstoffatom um also strikt von
wasserstoff sprechen zu können und die
erzeugung künstlicher energie zu nutzen
müssen wir diese abholerin den
sauerstoffatom trennen oder anders
ausgedrückt um ihnen auf unserem
planeten nutzen zu können müssen wir
wasserstoff herstellen kein prozess der
auf mehrere arten erreicht werden kann
wir werden uns das mal gleich ansehen
aber ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen das
ist eine der wichtigsten punkte dieser
ressource genau darin besteht dass es
mehr als einen weg gibt wenn sie
heranzukommen
aber wir wollen nicht soweit vorgreifen
eine freundin nie können wir wasserstoff
für die energiegewinnung nutzbar machen
was sind seine vorteile hat er wirklich
eine zukunft nun in diesem video werden
wir diese fragen beantworten wir werden
dabei ein element kennenlernen von dem
einige wissenschaftler glauben das ist
die lösung für fast alle energie und
klima probleme und herausforderungen
sein könnte denen wir gegenüberstehen
möchtest du dich uns also anschließen um
zu erfahren welche eine neue revolution
auf uns warten könnte lasst uns beginnen
[Musik]
der ultimative treibstoff
die meisten von uns wirkt dieses thema
ein wenig weit hergeholt erscheint aber
die wahrheit ist dass wasserstoff schon
seit vielen jahren in der industrie
eingesetzt wird tatsächlich werden
deshalb rund 70 millionen tonnen pro
jahr davon produziert eine zahl die sich
seit 1975 verdreifacht hat und derzeit
mit hoher geschwindigkeit wächst und
viele von euch werden sich fragen ok
aber was wir genau nutzt die industrie
den wasserstoff um die antwort lautet
hauptsächlich in der metallurgischen
industrie in raffinerien und in der
elektroindustrie sowie unter anderem zur
herstellung von düngemitteln und
harmoniert was sind seine aktuellen
haupteinsatzgebiete aber freunde
wasserstoff hat noch eine weitere
verwendung die für einen gewaltigen
unterschied in der ganzen welt
wirtschaft sorgen könnte
die gewinnung von elektrischer energie
und an dieser stelle müssen wir
natürlich erst mal über die wasserstoff
brennstoffzelle sprechen
diese zellen in gewisser weise an der
batterie aber anstatt mit strom
aufgeladen zu werden wie es bei
lithium-ionen-batterien den heutigen
elektroautos verwendet werden der fall
ist werden sie mit einem brennstoff in
diesem fall wasserstoff aufgeladen dh
diese technologie macht es möglich
elektrische energie zu gewinnen so was
auch immer wir wollen und erlaubt uns
auch sie zu speichern
aber dazu später mehr auf jeden fall
würden uns wasserstoff brennstoffzellen
auf diese weise ermöglichen ein
emissionsfreies auto zu benutzen und es
an einer wasserstofftankstelle in
wenigen minuten aufzuladen so dass wir
weitere 400 kilometer fahren könnten wir
müssen in wasserstoff meist in flüssiger
form einfach nur auftanken so als wäre
ist benzin diesel oder flüssiggas
aber wenn wir euch bereits gesagt haben
ist auf der erde kaum reiner wasserstoff
vorhanden und so müssen wir irgendwie
herstellen was ein paar fragen aufwirft
ist molekularen wasserstoff h2 teuer in
der herstellung wie vielfältig kann ist
eingesetzt werden und wie
umweltbelastend ist dieser ganze prozess
nun es kommt darauf an und das ganze mal
anschaulich darzustellen
je nachdem wie er hergestellt wird
können wir 38 von wasserstoff
unterscheiden grau blau und grün
damit meinen wir natürlich nicht dass es
wasserstoff in verschiedenen farben gibt
sondern einfach das ist verschiedene
rohstoffe und verschiedene methoden gibt
aus und mit denen wir ihn gewinnen
können fangen wir also mit dem grauen
wasserstoff an
[Musik]
ich habe unter euch haben sich ja schon
erkannt dass da wirklich grau in der
regel keine allzu guten und sauberen
assoziationen hervorruft und damit habt
ihr völlig recht denn der graue
wasserstoff ist jeder der schlicht und
einfach durch die verbrennung fossiler
brennstoffe wie kohle erzeugt wird aber
sprachen wir nicht über saubere energie
tja ironischerweise ist diese
herrschaftsform auch heute noch immer
gängige praxis
allerdings gibt es da weniger um die
idee dass dieser stoff für nachhaltige
mobilität gelöst sagte zum beispiel eben
in der industrie
es handelt sich um eine methode die
recht günstig ist die durchschnittlichen
kosten liegen bei nur einem dollar pro
kilogramm wasserstoff aber wie genau
funktioniert dieser prozess nun schauen
wir uns das mal
[Musik]
was der stoff kann aus kohle durch ein
prozess namens kohlevergasung gewonnen
werden auf dem video nicht näher
eingehen
bei dem aber synthesegas entsteht eine
verbindung die wasserstoff enthält der
dann aus dem gas extrahiert wird und der
punkt ist dass es zwei möglichkeiten
gibt die umweltschädlichen gase aus
diesen prozess loszuwerden
die traditionelle methode sie durch
einen stein in die atmosphäre zu blasen
oder sie in einem unterirdischen
reservoir zu speichern
das ist eine methode die zum beispiel im
elektro rallye in australien wird denn
australien ist sehr reich an kohle wenn
sie über saubere energie sprechen wäre
dies also durchaus noch eine akzeptable
methode das hauptproblem dabei werden
jedoch die kosten für die lagerung an
dieser gase in unterirdischen reservoirs
und auch die möglichen umweltrisiken wie
zb lex ins grundwasser aber die
möglichkeit dass es am ende zu
seismischen bewegungen kommen könnte wie
es in spanien beim castor projekt der
fall war
und genau hier kommt der blaue
wasserstoff ins spiel was man eben hat
diese bezeichnung bekommt nun denkt
daran was passiert wenn man erdgas
verbrennt genau dieser trend mit einer
blauen plane daher der name blauer
wasserstoff der hauptsächlich aus erdgas
gewonnen wird dies scheint heute die
vernünftigste alternative zu sein denn
glaubt mehr auf der welt gibt es so viel
erdgas das niemand wirklich weiß was man
damit eigentlich anfangen soll
in der tat sind öl produzierende länder
auf gezwungen diese ressource nutzlos
abzufackeln wenn sie bei der förderung
von erdöl auf erdgasvorkommen stoßen und
denkt nicht dass ich hier bei von irgend
einer bananenrepublik spreche das
abfackeln von erdgas ist eine relativ
gängige praxis selbst zum beispiel texas
[Musik]
für die produzenten setzen milliarden
von dollar in brand massive mengen an
erdgas wärme verbrannt und platz für die
ölförderung zu schaffen wenn die anreise
nicht geändert werden wird sich diese
schädliche praxis in den usa noch weiter
ausbreiten
[Musik]
zum beispiel wurden nach schätzungen der
weltbank im jahr 2018 weltweit 5,1 bio
erdgas abgefragt und einfach weil
niemand wusste was es uns damit tun
sollte
das entspricht dem verbrauch von
frankreich deutschland und belgien
zusammen einfach verrückt
[Musik]
das interessante und saubere an der
geschichte ist dass der blaue
wasserstoff nicht durch verbrennen des
erdgases geworden wird sondern durch die
sogenannte dampf formierung von erdgas
bei der methan und wasserstoff
kohlenmonoxid und wasserstoff reagieren
durch reaktion des kohlenmonoxids mit
noch mehr wasserdampf entsteht dann
kohlendioxid und weiterer wasserstoff
[Musik]
heute ist diese form der wasserstoff
erzeugung die am weitesten verbreitete
so sehr dass sechs prozent des gesamten
auf der erde verbrauchten erdgases zur
herstellung von wasserstoff verwendet
werden aber auch hier gilt und wo diese
methode viel sauberer ist als die mit
kohle ist das problem der co2 ausstoßen
derzeit werden nicht weniger als 95
prozent des weltweiten wasserstoffs mit
fossilen brennstoffen hergestellt und
zwar zu 75 prozent erdgas was bedeutet
dass jedes jahr 830 millionen tonnen
kohlendioxid durch diesen prozess in die
atmosphäre imitiert werden und das
entspricht der gesamten jährlichen
emission einer industrienationen wie
deutschland ein hinweis dazu es ist auch
üblich mit erdgas erzeugtem wasserstoff
als grauen wasserstoffs zeichnungen das
blaue label ausschließlich dem mit
erdgas erzeugten wasserstoff
vorzubehalten
dessen emissionen weitgehend aufgefangen
und unterirdisch gespeichert werden
dieses magische klassifizierung will
sich jedoch nicht klar festgelegt aber
moment mal wollten wir nicht über
saubere energie sprechen ok erdgas ist
viel weniger umweltschädlich als kohle
aber wenn die grenze wasserstoff
herstellen davon abhängt ich weiß nicht
es scheint keine so großartige
alternative zu sein zumindest nicht viel
besser als jene die wir bereits kennen
oder
mein leben freunde hier kommen wir zum
knackpunkt der ganzen geschichte mit den
richtig erinnert gab es nicht zwei oder
drei arten von wasserstoff oder dritte
das war der grüne wasserstoff und genau
dieser trödel wasserstoff könnten sich
die analysten experten und
wissenschaftler zum hauptakteur einer
ganz neuen energiewende werden hört
jetzt gut zu realität oder illusion wenn
wir von den revolutionären wasserstoff
brennstoffzellen autos hören die firmen
wie honda oder toyota entwickelt wurden
kommt muss ein neuer typ fahrzeug in den
sendern ein auto das die umwelt belastet
und in nur vier minuten vollgetankt
werden kann
tatsächlich geben die beiden derzeit
populärsten wasserstoffautos das modell
nexus phone you monday als auch der
mehrheit von trotha damit an dass ich
völlig saubere fahrzeuge sind die nur
reines wasser was den auspuff ausstoße
technisch gesehen sind die fahrzeuge des
versorger aber der punkt ist dass der
wasserstoff mit dem sie betrieben werden
ist nicht sein muss die einzige
möglichkeit diese kleine
unannehmlichkeit zu lösen ist derzeit
der sogenannte grüne wasserstoff der aus
erneuerbaren energien gewonnen wird
[Musik]
auf diese weise würde mit den strom der
mit hilfe erneuerbarer energie durch
einen prozess der als elektrolyse
bekanntes erzeugt wird dieser sauberen
strom versendung finden um das
wassermolekül h2o aufzuspalten und
wasserstoff zu erhalten das problem ist
dass dieses verfahren aufgrund des
enormen strombedarf derzeit sehr teuer
ist werden die herstellung von einem
kilo wasserstoff mit kohle etwa ein
dollar kosten würde schlägt die
herstellung mit erneuerbaren energien
zwischen 3 und 7 dollar auf 50 zu tun
und das ist ein sehr bedeutender
unterschied aber die kosten für
erneuerbare energien sinken sodass
technologischer fortschritt grünen
wasserstoff doch noch durchaus
konkurrenzfähig machen könnte was er
aber im moment halten nicht ist und
genau hier stellt sich die größten
fragen könnte wasserstoff wirklich der
kraftstoff der zukunft sein
[Musik]
aber um diese frage beantworten zu
können sollten wir uns vielleicht zuerst
eine andere frage stellen wofür genau
wollen wir diesen treibstoff was wollen
wir mit ihnen anstellen
wofür kann er verwendet werden
vielleicht ist wasserstoff für einige
anwendungsbereichen ja besonders gut
geeignet für andere nicht wie sich zum
beispiel mit einem normalen pkw aus die
anschaffung eines wasserstoff fahrzeugs
würde uns mindestens 60.000 dollar
kosten während ähnliche elektroautos für
die hälfte des preises werden können und
bisher ist der einzige spürbarer
unterschied die ladezeit etwas was auch
die elektroauto hersteller in den
nächsten jahren in den griff bekommen
wollen
zumindest haben sieht dass alle
angekündigt macht das wasserstoffauto
also sinn
okay die preise selber sicher sinken
wenn die technologie ausgereift ist und
genau das passiert ja jetzt mit den
elektroautos berücksichtigt aber all die
investitionen welche unternehmen und
regierungen in elektromobilität buttern
dann wetten zieht analysten einfach
darauf dass ein wasserstoffauto sich
nicht durchsetzen wird
aber lasst das mal ein bisschen weiter
in die zukunft und ein bisschen abseits
des mainstreams blicken zum beispiel auf
busse lastwagen oder sogar großer
handelsschiffe
es gibt zwar noch kein einziges
praktikables kommerziell erhältlich ist
elektro bus oder lkw modell mit
wasserstoffantrieb für den fernverkehr
aber was wenn die zukunft von
wasserstoff als transport kraftstoff
genau in diesem bereich liegt denkt
einen moment darüber nach welche art von
batterie bräuchte ein lkw oder bus um
eine anständige reichweite zu haben im
prinzip eine riesige batterie wie viel
laderaum einnehmen und auch das
fahrzeuggewicht staates erhöhen würde
ich bin sicher ihr alle habt schon mal
ein elektrisches stadtbus mit einer art
risiken buckel auf der oberseite oder
einem super dicken dach gesehen in denen
die batterie untergebracht ist ein
solcher ansatz scheint lange
überlandfahrten einfach nicht
praktikabel zu sein und ihr könnt ihr
wasserstoff ein kandidat sein dass du
einfach mal einen blick auf dieses
diagramm
[Musik]
voll alle emittierten treibhausgasen
entfallen 11 0% auf den straßenverkehr
und davon der 27 prozent von lkw und
bussen emittiert obwohl sie nur etwa 19
prozent aller welt bei zugelassenen
fahrzeuge ausmachen
was wäre aber wenn die wasserstoff
brennstoffzellen technologie für autos
an ein lkw oder bus angepasst werden
könnte was wäre wenn alle lkw und busse
mit wasserstoff betrieben würden und wir
dadurch mehr als ein viertel der
gesamten durch den landverkehr
verursachten umweltverschmutzung
minimieren würden sagt mir nicht dass
das nicht interessant klingt und nun
stellt euch das gleiche auch für große
handelsschiffe oder sogar
verkehrsflugzeuge vor die eine der
größten quellen also co2 emissionen
weltweit darstellen
er muss blickt mit wasserstoff
flugzeugen in die zukunft das
unternehmen sagte dass seine mit
wasserstoffbetriebenen
passagierflugzeuge bis 2035 einsatz
bereits an könnten natürlich befindet
sich diese pläne noch in einer eher
experimentellen phase aber egal ob es
sich um autos lastwagen busse oder gar
schiffe und flugzeuge handelt es gibt
gemeinsame hinter wisse welche die
mögliche breite nutzung dieser energie
um viele viele jahre zurückwerfen könnte
denn freunde wer sprechenden war ein
energieträger der zwar viele vorteile
hat aber auch viele herausforderungen
mit sich bringt also aufgepasst
eine energie die zu grün ist
[Musik]
ob er nun die energie alternative zu
kunst ist oder nicht wasserstoff als
kraftstoff hat noch einen langen weg vor
sich und das hauptproblem liegt nicht in
den kosten der brennstoffzellenautos und
auch nicht in der umweltverschmutzung
die bei der herstellung des wasserstoffs
entsteht das hauptproblem ist das ist
noch keine skaleneffekte wird diese
technologie gibt die nachfrage nach
wasserstoff ist nicht groß genug um eine
massenproduktion zum beispiel mit
erneuerbaren energien wirtschaftlich
sinnvoll zu machen und es gibt
sicherlich nicht genug nachfrage nach
wasserstoffautos im moment um ihre
preise so nach unten zu treiben wie ist
mit elektroautos geschieht und das
bedeutet wiederum das ist offensichtlich
nicht einmal genug nachfrage nach orten
gedanken denen man sein wasserstoffauto
auftanken kann
[Musik]
ein beispiel ist für korea dem land der
welt in denen diese technologie am
weitesten fortgeschritten ist und in
denen die meisten wasserstoff autos
verkauft werden
wurden im jahr 2009 10 nur ganze 5083
stück verkauft und das problem mit
wasserstoff liegt nicht nur in den
kosten von 70 bis 1000 dollar für einen
jungen max so wenn auch in der tatsache
dass ist die bereits erwähnt kaum
infrastruktur zu tanken gibt und das
trotz aller bemühungen der koreanischen
regierung ein mehr oder weniger
flächendeckendes netz von
wasserstofftankstellen zu schaffen
310 wasserstofftankstelle in korea bis
2022 ein ziel das die südkoreanische
regierung auf 450 wasserstofftankstelle
bis 2025 erhöht hat das bedeutet
natürlich dass eine menge öffentlicher
gelder auf den tisch gelegt werden
müssen damit will das land sein ziel
erreichen bis 2025 200.000 wasserstoff
autos auf die straße zu bringen hat
südkorea also die nase vorn weil dieser
neuen revolution
nun die zeit wird es zeigen klar ist das
ist nicht einfach ist eine neue
technologie von grund auf einzuführen
und sie bei den verbrauchern
durchzusetzen wenn kaum infrastruktur
bereit steht und auch die herstellung
von sauberen wasserstoff bis heute noch
ein teurer spaß ist natürlich wenn die
technologie weiter voranschreitet und
die kosten für sauberen strom weiter
sinken dann könnten wir uns auf eine
welt voller sauberer fahrzeuge schiffe
und flugzeuge freuen und dass meine
freude doch eine ziemlich coole aussicht
elektrofahrzeuge waren den
wasserstofffahrzeugen in bezug auf
entwicklung und akzeptanz nicht voraus
aber ich denke dass wasserstoff aufgrund
der fortschritte bei hochdruck
wasserstoffgas speicher und
brennstoffzellentechnologie und
wasserstoffproduktion aus erneuerbarer
energie aufholt john andrews professor
an der university in melbourne und alles
hätte ich was vergessen neben der
verwendung als kraftstoff ist einen
weiteren möglichen markt für wasserstoff
der sehr interessant ist habt ihr schon
mal darüber nachgedacht weil ich ein
riesiger fortschritt in sachen
energiewende es wäre wenn wir in der
lage wären die von windturbinen und
sonnenkollektoren erzeugter energie
effizient zu speichern und damit die
stromversorgung aus diesen quellen zu
ermöglichen selbst wenn gerade keine
sonne scheint und kein wind bläst nun
eine der ersten in betracht gezogene
option ist es dass es möglich sein
könnte erneuerbare energie zu speichern
indem man sie in wasserstoff umwandeln
dieser wasserstoff könnte dann für die
industrie zur wärmeerzeugung oder zum
antrieb von autos lkws schiffen oder
flugzeugen genutzt werden mit anderen
worten es wäre so etwas wie die
speicherung von überschüssigem strom
durch die erzeugung von wasserstoff der
gespeichert und dorthin transportiert
werden kann wo er benötigt wird wie
visual politik können uns natürlich
nicht so weit aus dem fenster lehnen zu
empfehlen auf diese technologie der
zukunft zu wetten ob wir eines tages auf
unseren straßen überall
wasserstofffahrzeuge sehen werden
oder jene dinge vertreten welche diese
technologie als hauptenergiequelle
nutzen werden was jedoch sagen können
ist dass die technischen entwicklungen
diesem bereich schnell und auch sehr
viel versprechende weise voran schreitet
aber was wird ihr darüber
meint ihr dass wasserstoff der
energieträger der zukunft werden könnte
glaubt ihr dass brennstoffzellenautos
das potenzial besitzen neben dem
elektroauto die fossilen brennstoffe zu
ersetzen oder handelt es sich vielleicht
um eine technologie die am ende nur in
ganz bestimmten bereichen zum einsatz
kommen wird
hinterlasst eure antworten bitte wie
immer in den kommentaren unter diesem
video
ich hoffe dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat asiatic uns mit einem
leicht ist mit euren freunden und
vergesst nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren
machs gut und bis bald